salut latine menthe à l'eau suite à la
vidéo d'hier où j'étais avec elie où
j'ai fait une addition très rapide j'ai
décidé de vous faire un master class
pour que vous puissiez faire pareil
content et très rapidement les additions
dans votre répète c'est une manière de
compter que j'ai appris dans un livre
quand j'étais petit l'édition originale
de ce livre s'appelle miracle' mater a
été édité en 1966 par harry de lorraine
le principe est simple c'est une
stratégie d'ascenseur nous allons faire
des allers-retours dans les chiffres
pour compte et n'importe quelle édition
très facilement très simplement et sans
erreur possible
imaginons que vous deviez additionner
tous et nous vend ensemble je sais que
là vous pouvez le faire de tête mais il
faut que vous compreniez exactement la
méthode de l'ascenseur nous allons quel
que soit l'addition partir du chiffre
en bas à gauche pour ensuite remonter et
à chaque changement de colonnes nous
redescendrons et si on doit rejoindre
cologne on remontera etc etc je prends
le chiffre en bas à droite dans ma tête
le 1 je fixe le 1-1 +34 +26 +17 aux
changements de colonne je colle le
prochain chiffre à celui que j'ai en
tête donc g7 en tête maintenant je vais
penser à 73 puisque je colle mon 3 à
mons est maintenant que j'ai mon 73 en
tête je descends en continuant mon
édition 73 76 77 79
mon résultat et donc de 79 l'exemple été
facile il n'y avait pas de retenue pour
que vous puissiez bien comprendre mais
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya des
retenues dans tous les sens exactement
la même chose je parte en bas à gauche -
8 8 et 4 ça fait douze et six ça fait 18
et 3 saf lui 21 j'ai donc 21 en tête
comme je viens de monter
maintenant je vais changer de colonne je
vais donc coller mon huit armes ont 21
surtout pas additionner je fais pas 21
plus 8,29 je colle mon prochain chiffre
à celui que j'ai en tête
donc ça nous fait 218 g 21 en tête et je
colle le 8 derrière et je parle de ceux
218 maintenant pour redescendre et
continuer mon édition 218 et 7 225 et 3
228 et 1 229 mon résultat final est donc
de 229
il ya eu des retenues elles se sont
intégrés il n'y a pas d'erreur possible
si vous avez des nombres à quatre
chiffres
c'est pareil on part d'en bas à gauche
on additionne en remontant ici on colle
à notre résultat on descend etc etc
la méthode de l'ascenseur un dernier
exemple très concret pour la route si
jamais vous tombez sur une édition à
faire
les nombres n'ont pas également le même
nombre de chiffres
donc on parle en bas à gauche là y'a
rien on voit que le premier c'est la
première dizaine 2010 qui est là le 5
c'est comme si je faisais zéro plus zéro
plus zéro + 5 j'ai mon 50 est je passe
ici donc je colle mon 3 au 5 ça nous
fait 53 53 je descends + 0 + 1 54 plus
déroger 54 en tête
je passe ici donc je colle le 1 je vais
le noter pour vous puissiez bien suivre
541 je remonte 549 et 1 550 j'en suis
donc à 550 en tête
je passe ici je colle mon 1 5501 je
descends 5503 5503 toujours 5504 ici
j'en suis à 5504 jeu colmont 6 ici pour
faire 55 min 46 55 1046 je remonte de 9
55 milles 55 et 4 55 1059 et 2,55 1061
pas d'erreur possible c'est forcément
juste puisque les retenues se sont
intégrés directement si vous vous
entraînez un petit peu ça va venir très
vite vous allez rapidement gagné en
vitesse et vous rendre compte à quel
point c'est très simple à faire
outre le fait de vous améliorer en
calculs mentaux de pouvoir même bluffé
les gens si vous voulez ça muscle en
plus le cerveau c'est très très bon pour
l'esprit
par contre ça veut dire désapprendre la
manière qu'on a de calcul est
aujourd'hui pour les additions on part
de la droite vers la gauche lampard de
la gauche vers la droite je vous
recommande donc vivement d'utiliser la
méthode de l'ascenseur pour faire vos
addition merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que le master class vous
a plu ça faisait très longtemps que
j'avais pas fais un sur les maths vous
ne m'avez demandé plusieurs fois
en voici un si vous voulez me soutenir
et soutenir cette vidéo vous pouvez
faire un petit ascenseur avec votre
pouce pour en faire un pouce en l'air
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo
puisque je le dis je vous le rappelle
tous les commentaires j'y réponds quand
je peux mais joli systématiquement
n'oubliez pas également de vous abonner
avant de quitter cette vidéo aussi je
trouve ça fait plusieurs fois que vous
regardez les vidéos vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné pourquoi parce que le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 11h ciao
je
oh